foreign
and welcome back to simple learns
YouTube channel today we have an
exciting topic for those of you who are
caught at the crossroads of choosing the
right career path business analyst
versus software developer we'll dive
into the key differences between these
two job rules explode their roles and
responsibilities and discuss the
essential skills required additionally
we'll touch upon salary variations
helping you make an informed decision so
if you are confused about which field to
push you this video is just for you
but before we begin with the video if
you enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best and
updated content for you daily also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply loon so without any further
delay let's start this video with who is
a business analyst and a software
developer a business analyst is a vital
link between the business world and the
tech real
they are responsible for analyzing an
organization's process identifying
problems and proposing solutions to
improve efficiency and productivity
software developers on the other hands
are tech savvy professionals who are The
Magicians behind the code creating the
software that makes businesses run
smoothly
so let's start with the skills required
to enter these fields
being a business analyst will require
you to master some skills a few of them
are analytical thinking ability to
analyze complex data and draw meaningful
conclusions this skill AIDS in
identifying business problems and
proposing effective Solutions
communication strong verbal and written
communication skills to articulate
requirements clearly effective
communication Fosters a smooth exchange
of information between various teams
problem solving adapt add identifying
problems and proposing effective
Solutions business analysts must be
solution oriented and think critically
domain knowledge familiarity with
industry or domain they are working in
understanding the business domain helps
them translate business requirements
into technical specifications
effectively and the last skill are the
tools Proficiency in Microsoft Excel
power bi or any other data analysis
software knowledge of data analysis
tools is crucial for interpreting and
presenting data driven insights
software developers on the other hand
requires a different set of skills some
of the most crucial skills acquired by
software developers are programming
Provisions in languages such as python
Java JavaScript C plus plus or others
based on the chosen domain
strong coding skills are the backbone of
software development the second skill is
problem solving strong analytical skills
to break down problems and device
efficient Solutions software developers
need to approach problems methodically
teamwork ability to collaborate
effectively with cross-functional teams
successful software development projects
require cooperation between other team
members
attention to detail precise coating and
thorough testing to deliver bug-free
software even small errors can have
significant impacts on the software's
functionality
the last skill is continuous learning a
mindset to stay updated with the latest
Technologies and Trends the tech
industry evolves rapidly and developers
must stay current to remain competitive
now that we know about the skills
required for both job rules let's talk
about the salary variations it's
essential to understand that salaries
can vary depending on factors such as
experience location and Industry
business analyst on an average business
analysts earn a competitive salary
according to Glasgow the average salary
of a business analyst goes around 9 lakh
rupees per year in India and in the
United States it goes around 94
521 dollars per annum with experience
and expertise these figures can increase
significantly
software developer software developers
also earn a rewarding salary
according to glassdo the average salary
of a software developer in India goes
around 8 lakh rupees per year and in the
United States the same software
developers earn around 105
889 dollars per annum senior developers
and those with Niche skills can command
even higher salaries
on that note if you want to master the
field of software development then
simply learns postgraduate program in
full stack in collaboration with Caltech
ctme can help you accelerate your career
as a software developer in just a few
months you'll learn modern coding
techniques with boot camp level
intensity and gain all you need to be a
full stack technologist this program
will give you the foundation for
building full stack web apps using Java
you will begin with the basics of java
and JavaScript and then Venture into
some of the more advanced concepts like
angular spring boot hibernate jsps and
MVC now is the perfect time to get
started on your career as a full stack
developer so what else can you expect
from this course this program includes a
Caltech ctme post graduate certificate
you'll attend master classes from
Caltech ctme instructors simply learns
job assist helps you get noticed by the
top hiring companies so if you want to
become a successful web developer then
this course by Caltech ctme is clearly
the right choice for you so check out
the link mentioned in the description
box below and enroll now not just that
but we can also help you become a master
of business analytics through a
postgraduate program in business
analytics in collaboration with Purdue
University
this program helps you learn how to
tackle complex business problems using
in-demand tools make the most of this
business analysis course with master
classes from Purdue University
this postgraduate program in business
analysis is for professionals looking to
pursue a business analysis career
understand business analysis techniques
get hands-on experience and for
experienced analysts looking to learn
the latest tools and Frameworks used by
the agile teams
this program will also help you master
high rated skills like business analysis
elicitation and collaboration BRD frdn
SRS document creation requirement
analysis data visualization and many
more so hurry up and enroll now the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so let's move ahead and understand
the rules and responsibilities of a
professional in both the domains we'll
start with business analyst the first is
requirement Gathering collaborate with
stakeholders to understand business
needs objectives and challenges they
must ask the right questions to alicide
detailed requirements
analysis and documentation analyze
gathered information and document
detailed functional requirements and
specifications
clear documentation ensures that the
development team fully understands the
Project's scope the third one is process
Improvement identify areas for process
Improvement and suggest optimized
workflows business analysts needs to
analyze current processes critically and
propose efficient changes the next is
data analysis utilize data analysis
tools to gather insights and make data
driven recommendations this skill helps
in understanding Trends identifying
patterns and making informed decisions
the last is testing and validation
validate the developed solutions to
ensure they meet the specified
requirements business analysts must
participate in testing to ensure the
software aligns with business needs
the roles and responsibilities of a
software developer differ from that of a
business analysts the most common roles
and responsibilities of a software
developer are software development
rightly in an efficient code for
application systems or websites based on
requirements software developers must be
proficient in various programming
languages and Frameworks
testing and debugging conduct rigorous
testing and debugging to ensure the
software's functionality and reliability
thorough testing helps identify and fix
issues before deployment continuous
Improvement stay updated with the latest
Technologies and development practices
to improve software quality software
developers need to be adaptable and
continuously enhance their skills
collaboration work closely with other
developers designers and stakeholders to
deliver high quality software
collaboration and Teamworks are
essential for successful project
delivery
problem solving find innovative
solutions to complex technical
challenges software developers encounter
various technical hurdles that require
creative problem solving
now comes the big question which path
should you choose the decision depends
on your interest strength and long-term
goals you should choose business
analysts if you enjoy working closely
with people and have a knack of
understanding business processes if you
are passionate about problem solving and
translating requirements into actionable
plans if you thrive in a dynamic
environment and continuous learning
opportunities
you should choose software development
if you have a strong passion for coding
and building software from scratch you
enjoy the challenge of creating
innovative solutions to real world
problems you are comfortable with
constant learning to keep up with the
rapidly evolving technologies have you
ever wondered how successful peoples can
be after opting for a postgraduate
program in business Analytics so let's
hear it from a learner who have
experienced massive success in their
career after choosing a postgraduate
program in business analytics hi I'm
Cortana I live in Raleigh North Carolina
and working as a business analyst at
reviture
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics I simply learned with puji
University my experience with simple
learning was great the live classes were
my favorite because they were very
interactive and I could connect with
instructors have many small gaps and
short employment in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind
it doesn't matter how challenging path
may be keep up scaling and one day you
will achieve successful ultimately both
business analysts and software
developers play crucial roles in the
tech industry whichever path you choose
remember that both offer exciting and
rewarding career opportunities take the
time to explore your interests skills
and what motivates you the most and
don't forget you can always switch
between roles if you discover new
passions along the way
if you found this video helpful give it
a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more
exciting content thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video Until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here